Отношение к покупкам вещей определяет
то, кем вы будете: богатым или бедным.
Главная проблема многих людей
заключается в том, что они неправильно
покупают вещи. Это вообще какой-то
большой глобальный баг, который сидит в
голове у каждого человека. Давайте
сегодня поговорим об этом. Давайте
представим обычную жизненную ситуацию.
Покупка телефона, автомобиля,
дома или каких-то вещей. Как через
покупку вещей можно определить, есть ли
в вашей голове баг или нет, правильно ли
вы мыслите или нет, и нас то, и то,
насколько эффективно ваше мышление. За
свой многолетний опыт я видел очень
много людей, и богатых, и бедных. И что
действительно прямо бросается в глаза,
это не то, что у кого-то есть больше
денег, у кого-то меньше денег, а в глаза
бросается закономерность,
связанная между мышлением человека и тем
состоянием, которое у него есть. Богатые
люди богаты не потому, что у них много
денег. Они, как правило, богаты потому,
что у них другой способ мышления. А
бедные, в свою очередь, остаются
бедными, опять-таки, из-за своих
ограничивающих убеждений. И сегодня мы
об этом поговорим. Дело в том, что я сам
вышел с далёкого
Аула, который находится в центре
Казахстана. Я там работал чабаном, а,
полтора года. Потом ушёл в армию, потом
поступил в университет и начал
заниматься бизнесом. То есть я
практически прошёл все стадии, а не
скажу, что не счеты, но и не такого, что
большого достатка. Я чётко понимаю, что
значит экономить деньги. Я чётко
понимаю, что значит, когда не хватает
денег. А я видел это на примере своих
родителей, я видел это на своих примерах
и так далее. И я тогда ещё не очень
понимал. Но сейчас, анализируя прошлое и
имея анализируя тот опыт, который я
имею, я вижу, насколько бедные
неправильно мыслят в отношении покупок.
Их неэффективное мышление приводит к
неэффективным покупкам. То есть сами
покупки являются следствием их
неэффективного мышления. И, кстати, ещё
когда я говорю о богатых и бедных, на
самом деле это условное разделение,
потому что я видел некоторых богатых с
бедным мышлением, но я видел некоторых
бедных, э, с эффективным, богатым
мышлением. И если наблюдать динамики, я
уверен, те люди, э, даже бедные на
сегодняшний день, но у которых в голове
эффективное мышление, рано или поздно
они станут богатыми. А те богатые люди,
которые имеют бедное, неэффективное
мышление - это только вопрос времени,
когда они потеряют свои деньги и своё
богатство. Потому что, э, есть много
богатых людей, которые получили своё
богатство незаслуженно. Там это было
наследство, либо они это сделали за счёт
взяток, либо они, а, используя какие-то
близость к власти и так далее. Поэтому,
когда мы говорим сегодня о разнице
отношений к покупкам между богатыми и
бедными, это, я говорю не про то
состояние, которое у них есть сейчас,
это про способ мышления. В чём состоит
мышление бедного человека, которое
проявляется в неправильных или в
неэффективных покупках? Первое, конечно-
это самый низкий уровень, когда бедные
люди очень бедные, им приходится реально
экономить на всём. Им приходится
экономить на всём, и они покупают всё
дешёвое. И, к сожалению, у них даже нет
возможности думать о покупках каких-то
дорогих вещей. А-а, ну и вообще они даже
голову поднять не могут от своей
бедноты, нищеты. Каким бы человек не был
нищим и бедным,
я всё равно считаю, что у него есть
ресурсы. Не бывает человека без
ресурсов. Просто мы все привыкли думать,
что ресурсы - это только деньги. Но
смотрите, у бедного человека, да, нету
денег или их очень мало, но у него очень
много времени, у него есть энергия. Если
он молодой человек, то у него есть ещё
молодость. Поэтому те излишки ресурсов,
которые у них есть, надо прежде всего
направлять на приобретение знаний и
развитие самого себя. То есть начните
с инвестирования в самого себя, но не
денег, а времени и своей энергии. Если
мы будем брать эту категорию людей, то
они основная ошибка, я считаю, в том,
что они всё время гоняются за дешёвыми
вещами. То есть для них вот в голове
стоит такое ограничение, что покупать
только дешёвые вещи. В чём подвох или
неэффективность такого мышления? Дело в
том, что когда вы покупаете дешёвые
вещи, вы тем самым практически убиваете
свою самооценку.
Вы всё время её понижаете. И плюс
дешёвые вещи долго не служат. Они долго
не служат, и вам приходится всё чаще и
чаще покупать их. Поэтому, если
просуммировать ту функцию, которую
выполняет дешёвая вещь, и ту функцию,
которую выполняет дорогая вещь, и
разделить это на цену, то очень часто
выясняется, что дорогая вещь или
качественная вещь гораздо дешевле, чем
дешёвая. Вторая неэффективность
заключается в том, что многие бедные
люди покупают вещи на показ. Они
покупают не для себя, они как бы
показывают для того, чтобы показывать
эту вещь, то есть сравниваться с кем-то.
В этом мире вы никогда не сможете
кого-то по-настоящему впечатлить. Всегда
есть кто-то, кто круче, кто богаче и так
далее. Поэтому надо исходить из своих
целей, а не из целей других людей. Не
надо пытаться соревноваться с кем-то.
Поэтому, когда вы покупаете вещь, вы
должны покупать функцию, которая
выполняет эта вещь для вас, какую
функцию для вас она выполняет, и не
ориентироваться на то, какую функцию она
выполняет для других. Например, когда
там студент или, а, наёмный служащий,
который живёт от зарплаты до зарплаты,
покупает себе iPhone. Спрашивается,
зачем ему iPhone? Есть куча дешёвых э
смартфонов на Андроиде. Опять-таки
вопрос даже не в том, что покупка
Андроида. Вопрос нужно чётко понимать, а
для чего он тебе нужен. Если он нужен
тебе для того, чтобы там просто сёрфить
в социальных сетях, то гораздо было бы
эффективнее иметь кнопочный телефон.
Гораздо эффективнее было бы иметь
кнопочный телефон по одной простой
причине, что вы на нём не можете
соёрфить или лазить в социальных сетях и
благодаря этому сэкономить огромное
количество времени и энергии. Или
возьмём ситуацию, когда человек
покупает, а, дорогой автомобиль. Это
приводит к третьей проблеме в мышлении
бедных людей, в том, что они не
учитывают цену владения. Вот цена
владения - это большой вопрос. Проблема
вот, э, бедного мышления очень часто
заключается в том, что люди не знают и
не видят э цену владения. Я, когда
покупаю какие-либо вещи, я всегда задаю
пять вопросов. Первый вопрос: мне
действительно это надо или нет? Второе,
а-а, как долго я буду этим пользоваться?
Третье, как часто я буду этим
пользоваться. Четвёртое, можно ли это
взять в аренду? Пятое, какова цена
владения? И ещё шестой дополнительный
вопрос: а какова цена будет, если я это
продам после использования? И вот цена
владения, это включает налоги. Если вы
купили автомобиль, вы ежегодно платите
налоги. Если вы купили автомобиль, вы
ежегодно меняете шины, вы меняете
фильтры и так далее масла и так далее.
Это всё цена владения. А здесь я особо
хотел бы ещё отметить такую вещь, что у
вас могло сложиться впечатление, что я
говорю о том, что дорогие вещи всегда
лучше. Дело в том, что не всегда дорогая
вещь, она самая лучшая, но и не всегда
дешёвая вещь, она самая худшая. Но для
того, чтобы понимать, как я говорил, вы
всегда любую вещь оцениваете через
функцию, для чего она вам нужна. И очень
часто бывает так, что вот вы купили
дорогую вещь, она сама по себе
качественная, но цена владения очень
дорогая. Например, когда вы покупаете
дорогой автомобиль, тот же Mercedes
Rolls-Royce, вы один раз потратили одно,
но там же ещё налоги выше, там фильтра
дороже, покрышки стоят дороже, страховка
дороже там и всё, и всё это дороже, цена
владения. И таким образом, если
суммировать истинную стоимость вещей, а
она состоит из двух вещей:
первоначальная цена, первоначальная
сумма, которую заплатили, и цена
владения, то может оказаться, что вы
купили функцию очень дорого. Функцию,
которую выполняет этот автомобиль,
например, или эта вещь, очень дорого.
Поэтому обязательно на это тоже надо
обращать внимание.